willkommen zur letzten folieung zum
Thema Philosophie der virtuellen
Realität wir blicken heute zurück auf
das was wir in den letzten Tagen in den
letzten Vorlesungen gemacht haben wir
haben sehr viel gemacht und wir geben
erst einmal einen kurzen Rückblick zum
Thema virtuelle Kunst möchte ich Ihnen
auch kurz nach so ein paar Punkte nennen
die mir noch Erinnerung geblieben sind
wie auch wohl sehr zentral sind wir
hatten in der vorletzten Sitzung der
vorletzten Vorlesung die Frage nach dem
virtuellen Handlungsraum behandelt
wir hatten gesehen dass die
Handlungsraum dass das Handeln in
virtueller Hinsicht viel mit
kommunizieren zu tun hat mit dem
Austausch von Informationen wir haben
aber auch gesehen dass
Austausch von Informationen nicht nur
irgendwie so eine Plauderei ist
sondern dass Austauschen von
Informationen sehr komplex sein kann und
das
Informationsaustausch durchaus auch als
Handlung aufgefasst werden kann häufig
ist es im Alltag in der physischen Welt
nicht so sichtbar weil der Handlung
häufig ganz stark mit körperliche Aktion
verbunden wird ja ich Fälle einen Baum
das ist eine Handlung ich bewege mich
wohin
allerdings zeigt uns schon unsere
Sprache dass wir auch mit Sprache etwas
tun kannst können zum Beispiel durch
Sprechakte
und wenn wir handeln können durch
Informationsaustausch wenn auch
Informationsaustausch eine Form von
Handlung ist
ich glaube dann lässt sich das natürlich
auch wunderbar virtualisieren weil wir
sehen können vom Brief schreiben hin zum
E-Mail verschicken
da haben wir den Übergang der
Virtualisierung und
ebenso kann man dann einen Raum wo man
eben digital
kommunizieren kann als einen digitalen
Handlungsraum ansehen jetzt ist aber der
entscheidende Unterschied zum physischen
Handlungsraum dass der virtuelle
Handlungsraum zu glaube ich jedenfalls
rückgebunden ist an die Art und Weise
wie wir handeln
wenn wir so informationell virtuell
handeln dass wir Blasen erzeugen dass
wir uns abkapseln dass wir uns aus dem
öffentlichen Diskurs zurückziehen dann
deformieren wir den virtuellen
Handlungsraum also unser Handeln im
virtuellen Raum ist in einem Art von
Wechselverhältnis zu verstehen zu diesem
Handlungsraum und wir vergrößern diesen
Handlungsraum wenn wir eben sinnvolle
Verbindungen herstellen zum Beispiel
über Wikipedia ich habe ja gesagt eine
ganz kleine Korrektur im Wikipedia
Artikel hilft dazu den virtuellen
Handlungsraum zu vergrößern warum weil
der virtuelle Handlungsraum ein
cyber-space ist und ein Cyber Space ist
ein navigationsraum von griechisch
übernächst ist ja das heißt Räumlichkeit
wird ganz stark im virtuellen auch über
den Begriff der Orientierung der
Navigation
definiert ich sage wirklich definiert
definiert heißt abgegrenzt haben wir uns
ja physische Dimensionen fehlen es
fehlen ja die drei Dimensionen des
physikalischen physischen Raumes im
virtuellen Raum wobei man sie simulieren
kann kann Räumlichkeit simulieren aber
sie ist eben künstlich erzeugt sie ist
eine Simulation das was eigentlich
virtualisiert ist ist die
Orientierung und die Kommunikation
die wir als Handel verstehen können das
heißt der Raum vergrößert sich im
virtuellen wenn wir ihn
besser definieren wenn durch die
Art der Kommunikation die eben eine
öffentliche Form von Kommunikation sein
muss die Navigation
vergrößert verbessern die Orientierung
verbessern und das ist natürlich
entgegengesetzt zum
Blasen Phänomen was wir eben durch
künstlichen Intelligenz auch immer mehr
kennenlernen und in diesem virtuellen
Handlungsraum können wir auch Kunst
produzieren Kunst realisieren
virtuelle Kunst ist häufig deutlich
erkennbar durch die Technologie der
Digitalisierung wie ich schon oft sagte
Digitalisierung heißt noch nicht
Virtualisierung nicht alles was digital
ist es virtuell und nicht alles was
virtuelles ist digital
es gibt eben auch wie wir gesehen haben
Banknoten die ein Wert haben der dem
Papier für sich nicht zukommt diese
Banknote ist kein digitales Phänomen
anders sieht es aus wenn wir es jetzt
mit
Internetphänomen zu tun haben die sind
natürlich auch gebunden an Technik
vielleicht auch irgendwie an Materie
aber nicht mehr so eindeutig an mattiere
wie jetzt ein Wert an ein Geldschein
warum das ist eine viel eindeutigere
Beziehung sagen Sie mal wo auf Ihre
Festplatte bitte jetzt die zehn Bitcoins
ist oben rechts unten die Frage ergibt
eigentlich keinen Sinn
genauso wenig ergibt die Frage sind wo
ihr Bankguthaben jetzt ist wo die 1000
Euro auf ihren Bankkonto sieht ja auf
den bankkont aber wo ist das Bankkonto
im Server links oben rechts wird ja
ständig auch gespiegelt wird ja
selbstständig auch umgeordnet die
räumlichkeitsfrage ist vielleicht nicht
ganz von der Hand zu weisen irgendwo
muss es ja zumindest
konstituiert werden durch irgendwelche
materielle Dinge aber wo genau die
Lokalisierbarkeit die ja häufig auch mit
Räumlichkeiten Verbindung gebracht wird
und die möglich ist wenn sie zum
physische Gegenstände handelt die ist so
nicht mehr möglich genauso kann man sich
jetzt fragen wie es mit der Zeitlichkeit
aussieht seit wann existiert das wie
existiert das in der Zeit auch das
scheint mir auch eine andere Weise
zeitlich geordnet zu sein der zeitliche
Aspekt scheint nicht mehr so wichtig zu
sein und diese Unabhängigkeit von
Räumlichkeit und Zeitlichkeit die
erlaubt eben negative Freiheit von
erlaubt den positiven Hinsicht neue
Möglichkeiten Flexibilisierungen
Vernetzungen Verbindungen reibungslose
Vernetzungen Integrationen Stichwort
sieben lässt das ist nur dann möglich
wenn wir uns von diesen räumlichen und
zeitlichen Fixierungen die eben das
physische noch hat und was wir auch bei
Geldscheinen obwohl sie virtuelle
Realitäten sind immer noch sehen möglich
ist
virtuelle Kunst ist jetzt also nicht auf
die Technik der Digitalisierung zu
reduzieren genauso wie natürlich auch
ein Gemälde von Picasso nicht darin
aufgeht in seinem ästhetischen Wert dass
wir sagen da ist so und so viel Farbe
diesen Chips kann man chemisch
analysieren auf dieser Leinwand dieses
Chips mit einem Rahmen dieses Holzes
damit erklären Sie nicht den
ästhetischen Wert eines Kunstwerks sie
fassen damit nicht was ein Kunstwerk ist
genauso wenig wie man nicht über
Schallwellen eine Symphonie erklären
kann durch das physikalische Phänomen
von Druck und Stoß auf unsere Trommel
und die Information Weiterleitung ans
Gehirn neuronale Bildgebung welche
emotionalen Zentren dadurch irgendwie
aktiviert werden das können sie machen
aber damit erklären Sie nicht den
ästhetischen Gehalt sie erklären ihr den
physischen physiologisch behalten
psychologischen Gehalt eines sinnvoll
der natürlich auch immer von Individuum
verschieden ist wir mögen drei
verschiedene Personen diese Musik
aussetzen in ihrem Gehirn spielt sich
jeweils was anderes AB zumindest in
verschiedenen Hinsicht werden emotionale
Zentrum aktiviert das wird ja nicht
immer dasselbe sein
virtuelle Kunst gehorcht also einen
anderen Raum Zeit Logik als physische
Kunst unten neuer Punkt ist auch noch
Kunst und künstliche Intelligenz wirken
zusammen in der Kunst es ist deswegen
interessant weil in der künstlichen
Intelligenz ja auch das Wort Kunst drin
enthalten ist auch im englischen haben
wir ja artificial intelligence
lateinisch Kunst auch damals drin jetzt
kann man sich fragen ist künstliche
Intelligenz als solche schon eine
virtuelle Form von Kunst er ist
künstlichen Intelligenz schon Kunst naja
sie ist künstlich technisch erzeugt aber
jetzt natürlich nicht im ästhetischen
Sinne das sind keine ästhetischen
Gedanken zunächst mal dahinter das heißt
aber nicht dass man künstlichen
Intelligenz auch in ästhetischen
Kontexten einbeziehen kann
und jetzt hatten wir ein Beispiel
diskutiert konkretes Beispiel virtuelle
Kunst das waren neue Token nfcs oder
hatten wir auch eine Studierende hier
die sich sehr gut aus kannte ich wollte
aber trotzdem noch mal ein paar Dinge
nachtragen ein nonable Token ist ein
nicht austauschbares
individuelles und einmaliges digitales
Unikat
es lässt sich in Analogie oder im
Verhältnis der Virtualisierung
vielleicht genauer gesagt zu einem
physischen indikatverstehen ist jetzt
ein NFC eine bloße digitale Simulation
eines physischen Unikats oder ist es
eine Virtualisierung eines physischen
Unikats ich glaube es ist eine
Virtualisierung eines physischen Unikats
weil es genau dieselben Zwecke erfüllt
und neue Möglichkeiten eröffnet
dieses Gedanke dieser Gedanke der
Individualisierung des Unikats ist der
Kunst häufig inhärent es gibt
verschiedene Bewegungen im 20
Jahrhundert die diesen Gedanken der
Einmaligkeit der
unikatsmäßigen Verfasstheit von Kunst
entgegengewirkt haben natürlich auch aus
ästhetischen Gründen Andy Warhol war das
der hat Massenproduktion gemacht
Siebdruck Verfahren am laufenden Bandit
hat er perfektioniert den Siebdruck und
hatte einfach für jedermann geht das
auch Kunst machen wollte das war sein
Verständnis von Kunst natürlich nicht
ohne Grund in den USA der 50er wo ja
auch diese Pop Art und auch diese
Ökonomisierung extrem zugenommen hatte
er hat das natürlich auch in seiner
Kunst reflektiert sie kennen alle diesen
Spruch in der Zukunft wird jeder dafür
ein paar Minuten berühmt werden wenn Sie
diesen Spruch berühmt sein das ist
natürlich gerade dieser populäre
gesellschaftliche Anspruch der Kunst
das hatte auch eben dadurch gemacht dass
er weggegangen ist von dem Gedanken der
Exklusivität von Kunst von dem Unikat er
hat es verfügt also nicht desto Trotz
hat natürlich jedes seiner
verfielfältigen Werke ein extrem hohen
Wert es kann sich natürlich nicht
jedermann ins Zimmer hängen geht eben
gar nicht ja also da hat das nichts
gebracht vielleicht war das sogar ein
cleverer Trick dass er noch mehr Geld
machen kann ja würde ich nie
unterstellen aber sie sehen Kunst und
Kommerz hängen ganz eng miteinander
zusammen und die Digitalisierung ist
eigentlich eine Technologie die sowas
wie Individualisierung oder auch die
Karte nicht ermöglicht weil sie ja die
Datenstrukturen eins zu eins kopieren
und vervielfältigen können ja angenommen
sie mal ein Bild und digitalisieren das
im Sinne eines
digitalen Abbildes und ich hätte mich in
Ihr System hinein und kopiere mir das
genau die identische Datenstruktur
das hat genau diese Mannschaft ja
vielleicht ist ein metadat von
verschiedenen das wenn wir das erstellt
hat und das ist aber auch das sollte
nicht der Fall sein es ist möglich dass
selbst eine Metadaten manipuliert werden
das ist wirklich in jeder Hinsicht
identisch ist numerische identisch ist
numerisch was alle Null und Eins
anbelangt ja also checkst du mir mit der
der Daten Informationen und so weiter
und so fort es ist prinzipiell möglich
dass es genau dieselbe Anzahl von
und dann haben Sie ein Problem dann habe
ich nämlich ihr Unikat zerstört wenn ich
davon eine digitale Kopie mache und das
ist ja der Vorteil einerseits der
Digitalisierung dass man wirklich
numerische identische Duplikate
herstellen kann weil man durch dieses
numerische identische Objektivität
generiert kann das ist im physischen so
nicht möglich diese numerische Identität
sie haben eine Flasche desselben Typs
ist natürlich auch nicht dieselbe die
nicht die genau dieselben Eigenschaften
praktischer Hinsicht schon aber da fehlt
hier noch ein Molekül oder jeden Atomen
Atom ihrer Flasche das ist nie materiell
identisch hallo ähm das heißt diese
diese Objektivität kriegen sie sehr
leicht sehr gut durch Digitalisierung
aber jetzt wollen sie in der Kunst
gerade nicht diese vielfältigbarkeit
haben sie wollen die Karte haben und
deswegen müssen sie jetzt versuchen auf
die digitale Weise diese individuelle
Struktur einzutragen
und das geht eben dadurch dass sie nfts
durch die Technologie der blockchain
individualisieren
vielleicht haben Sie schon mal die
blockchain-technologie gehört das ist
die Technologie die auch den Bitcoins
zugrunde liegt blockchain heißt es eine
Kette eine lange Kette von Blocks und
jeder Bitcoin setzt sozusagen an die
bestehende Kette die überall präsent ist
einen neuen Block dran und zeigt dadurch
dass er Kontinuität zu allen bisherigen
Verfahren herstellt also es ist ein
objektivitätsverfahren auch ein
Sicherheitsverfahren mit dieser
blockchain können Sie sicherstellen dass
niemand betrügt
und genauso werden dann nfts wir haben
gesehen zum Beispiel Bilder von
gelangweilten Affen die extreme Werte
mittlerweile bekommen
auf ein auf Basis dieser blockchain
durch ein Sicherheitsverfahren als
Originale ausgewiesen
und das ist dann häufig auch verknüpft
mit einem Unikat mit einem Zertifikat
dass man sieht dieses digitale Objekt
obwohl es beliebig vervielfältigbar ist
ist doch am Ende des Original und dieses
nicht das ist alles passiert alles auf
dieser ganz komplexen Technologie der
blockchain gibt auch andere Technologien
und damit soll eben diese Objektivität
geleistet werden ich glaube das ist ein
paradigmatischer Fall von virtueller
Kunst weil hier derselbe Zweck erhalten
bleibt uns bekommt ein Wert Kunst
bekommt ein Unikat Status Kunst hat
einen Künstler eine Künstlerin und
jemand der kauft und Kunst hier in
diesem Fall virtuelle Kunst lässt ganz
neue Möglichkeiten zunächst die
Verwendung der virtuellen Kunst im
virtuellen Handlungsraum ich kann mich
im virtuellen Handlungsraum mit
Traversen damit schmücken ich kann mich
auf Instagram damit schmücken ja also
sie können diese Kunst so verwenden so
wie sie auch im physischen Hinsicht in
ihrem Alltag verwenden können wir sind
noch kurz auf Kunst und künstliche
Intelligenz eingegangen Mensch Maschine
Interaktion ist ein wichtiges Stichwort
wir gehen wir mit der KI um diese
mensch-maschinen Interaktion kann
natürlich auch und der ästhetischen
Gesichtspunkten verwendet werden ganz
klar wir müssen KI nicht nur dazu
verwenden Texte zu übersetzen das wäre
natürlich auch den menschenmaschine
Interaktion sondern wir können sie eben
auch mit ästhetischen Gesichtspunkten
betrachten ich habe das eine ästhetische
interobjektivität genannt nicht
Intersubjektivität weil natürlich
künstliche Intelligenz kein Subjekt ist
es aber auch irgendwie kein wirkliches
Objekt wie jetzt so eine Flasche ja
künstliche Intelligenz hat ganz starken
Prozess Charakter deswegen spreche ich
jetzt hier von Inter Objektivität
künstliche Intelligenz ist irgendwas
zwischen Subjekt und Objekt es ist kein
Gegenstand es ist eher ein Prozess und
es ist ein Prozess der eben auch auf
sich selbst Bezug nimmt zum Beispiel
durch Feedback Schleifen durch
Selbstlernen und so weiter also eine
ganz spannende Sache und wir stehen
natürlich auch mit der KI immer in
Kontakt indem wir die Datenbasis liefern
also komplexes Verhältnis ich glaube
aber doch dass man das ästhetische
stehen kann
ich glaube auch dass im ästhetischer
Hinsicht Kunst nicht künstliche
Intelligenz nicht adäquat als ein
Werkzeug verstanden werden kann wie ein
Hammer ja es ist nicht so wie wenn Sie
jetzt mit einem Hammer eine Statue
Meißel aus einem Block heraus dass sie
auch so künstlichen Intelligenz
verwenden ich glaube dass das nicht die
richtige Analogie ist er ist künstliche
Intelligenz die Virtualisierung eines
Werk
s aber nicht die Simulation und direkt
Abbildung es gibt nämlich ein sehr
ergibt ein kreativen Zusammenhang sind
von virtueller Kunstproduktion man kann
von einer virtuellen Muse sprechen die
künstliche Intelligenz die liefert Ihnen
durch gewisse musste Erkennungsverfahren
interessante Vorlage aus z.B der
Gesamtheit all ihre bisherigen Bilder da
variiert könnte Intelligenz diese Muster
dieses Strukturen erkennt neue musste
die sie bisher noch nicht gesehen haben
und so kann es durchaus auch als Quelle
der Modifikation Variationen
Transformation verwendet werden aber KI
ist natürlich als solche noch nicht
kreativ ja sie lässt sich aber in
kreativ im momentan kreative Prozesse
integrieren im Sinne der Mensch-Maschine
Interaktion dann kann künstliche
Intelligenz zu Überraschungen und neuen
Perspektiven führen die eben uns
wiederum inspirieren können würde aber
nicht sagen dass künstliche Intelligenz
selbst
inspirierend also selbst Inspirationen
hat oder selbst kreativ ist das wären
mein Augen ein Kategorienfehler wird mir
nämlich künstlichen Intelligenz
personifizieren